so etwas hat er noch nie gesehen
bayerische erntehelfer liegend auf einer
pritsche während der erntewagen weiter
rollt sie pflücken biologisch angebaute
golden
david flores kommt aus ecuador er ist
bio zertifizierer und nur für kurze zeit
in deutschland zu besuch
er will sich ein paar biobetriebe
genauer anschauen
hier scheint das sehr effektiv und
schnell zu sein und das personal muss
ich auch nicht so anstrengend wie wenn
es sich bei der ernte körper umhängen
oder aufladen muss ja mir erscheint das
sehr praktisch
und das ist sein deutscher kollege beide
arbeiten für dieselbe firma einen
internationalen bio zertifizierer egal
ob in ecuador oder deutschland sie sind
viel unterwegs schauen sich betriebe wie
diesen bio bauernhof bei münchen an
oliver koch nimmt seinen job sehr ernst
kniet sich dafür in jedes gemüse feld
und sieht einfach vielfalt zwischen den
pflanzen vielleicht auch noch
irgendwelchen über platte von möglichen
betriebsmittel sind wir einfach der
boden aus zu wie sich die pflanze
entwickelt hat was einfach und gut zu
sehen ist was eben auf den ersten blick
nicht auffällt in seiner heimat prüft
david flores auf die gleiche weise die
bioprodukte werden aber größtenteils
exportiert da muss langsam an bio
produkte zu akzeptieren oder sogar zu
konsumieren
deshalb glaube ich es ist ein prozess
der hoffentlich nicht zu lange dauert
bis wir verstehen welche vorteile uns
diese ernährungsform bringen kann
in lateinamerika ist das größte problem
der gebrauch oder der missbrauch von
insektiziden und pestiziden und
chemischen substanzen
david flores will noch eine andere firma
sehen
nächste station ist die bio brauerei
neumarkter lammsbräu
hier trifft er den spezialisten für das
brauereiwesen das ist neuland für david
flores er hat noch die eine brauerei von
innen gesehen
sein kollege prüft alle rohstoffe für
die bierherstellung bis ins kleinste
detail auch ein betriebsrundgang gehört
zu jeder kontrolle dazu ob bio wirklich
bio ist und was passiert wenn die prüfer
verstöße feststellen
dann gibt es einen maßnahmenkatalog der
wir von einem mündlichen schriftlichen
hinweis bis zu einer abmahnung und
gegebenenfalls im schlimmsten fall sogar
zu einem verbreitungsgebiet führen kann
um das zu verhindern prüft manfred böhm
alle rechnungen und belege was sie auf
deutsch diskutieren geht an david flores
vorbei aber papierkram ist auch für ihn
in ecuador ein großteil seiner arbeit
sind die prozesse ähnlich es gibt ein
dokumentationssystem um alles zurück zu
verfolgen und es gibt enorme
qualitätsanforderungen man fordert viel
damit sie diese zertifizierung bekommen
es ist die gleiche die sie hier
ausstellen mit dem dokumentationssystem
um das produkt zu beschreiben und auf
die nahrungsmittel aufzupassen die sie
vertreiben
in der brauerei wird neben bier auch bio
cola abgefüllt
aber davon ist man in seiner heimat noch
ganz weit weg